imagine going to a coffee shop and
connected to the free Wi-Fi names coffee
free Wi-Fi it's pretty normal right but
sometimes that normal looking Wi-Fi is
actually hosted by a random person
trying to impersonate the free Wi-Fi
access and steal your data once you log
into your email or Worse your bank
account your data can be compromised yes
there's a lot of Bad actors out there on
the internet fortunately today's video
is sponsored by nordvpn which is helping
give internet users all the tricks and
tools of a proper 21st century online
experience look you might have heard me
talk before about what nordvpn can do
for you encrypt your internet data move
your online activity to another location
with just one click either for Superior
security or new streaming options and
all that's still true nor VPN has more
than 5 500 servers spread across 59
countries but vpns give you access to so
much more than new TV shows with nordvpn
you really can do it all and that
includes utilizing their threat
protection upgrade which blocks ads
eradicates web trackers checks for
malware and right now as part of a
unique deal you guys can get a two-year
plan at a huge discount plus an
additional formats for free then if you
try Nord and change your mind they offer
a 30 day money back guarantee all you
got to do is go to nordvpn.com bio again
nordvpn.com bio for a two-year deal at a
huge discount plus four free months on
top of that as a bonus or just follow
the link in the description box below
and now today's video
really very rarely and Ashley comes
along that transcends the sports pages
and becomes an international icon
they're so good they become permanently
associated with that sport like Michael
Jordan basketball and Wayne Gretzky in
hockey so famous that even if you know
nothing about the sport itself you know
their names we call these athletes
Superstars and there is perhaps no
better example of a sports Superstar The
Babe Ruth everyone knows who Babe Ruth
is we are almost a century on from his
accomplishments on the baseball diamond
and we are still talking about what he
did that staying power that few sports
figures can match he was so good at
baseball that the game itself changed to
better suit his play style and has never
gone back to the way it was before he
came along everybody loved him even when
he got into trouble which he did
frequently the problem with Babe Ruth is
that there are so many myths and legends
around him that they get confused with
the facts and this happens to the point
that at times it's difficult to pin down
who he was or to quantify how important
he was the game of baseball in American
history sure everyone knows who Babe
Ruth was but do they actually the story
of Babe Ruth is a baseball story short
but it's also a human story and those
are always the hardest ones to tease out
of the pages of history and Legend
her most of his life George Herman Ruth
Jr thought he'd been born on February
7th 1894. that was what his parents had
told him after all it wasn't actually
until later in life when he applied for
a passport that he discovered that his
birth certificate said that had been
born on February the 6th 1895. like many
things about the Ruth Legend no one is
really sure for the reason in this
discrepancy he was born in Baltimore
Maryland in a tough working-class
neighborhood on the waterfront his
father ran a saloon and apparently a
little time to raise a son who ran wild
in the streets and became a delinquent
at the age of seven he was sent to Saint
Mary's Industrial school for boys a
combination reform school in orphanage
run by the Xavier and brothers a
Catholic religious order it was a grim
placed a grout with conditions similar
to a prison Ruth would spend over a
decade there the brothers at St Mary's
like men any such institutions encourage
their charges to participate in
athletics believing it would keep them
in good health and cut down on the
amount of trouble they got into the most
popular sport played at the school was
baseball this is hardly surprising
baseball had become the most popular
sport in America over the last 20 years
everyone played from schoolboys all the
way up to the major leagues which had
contested the first World Series in
1903. Ruth loved baseball and it soon
became apparent that he was good at it
too a samaris he usually played on the
team of boys several years older than he
was and by the time he was 16 he was the
school's best player he became a pitcher
the player responsible for throwing the
ball to opposing hitters to try and get
them out and he was so talented that
Jack Dunn the owner of the minor league
Baltimore oracles signed him to a
professional contract in January 1914 at
the age of either 19 or 20 depending on
which date of birth you use finally
released from the walls of Saint Mary's
the young Ruth wanted to see everything
he wanted to do everything experience
everything all at once he was naive
about the world in a way that Charmed
his teammates who soon gave him the next
babe because he looked and acted like a
big kid the nickname stuck and for the
rest of his life hardly anyone ever
called him George Ruth may have been a
kid but he pitched like a seasoned Pro
he won 14 games for the Orioles in half
a season with the team before done beset
by money trouble sold Roots contract the
Boston Red Sox he did this alongside
another pitcher Ernie Shaw Babe Ruth was
already on his way to the big leagues
we didn't play very much for Boston in
1914 his breakthrough came the next year
when he won 18 games and helped them win
the American League Championship known
as a pennant before defeating the
Philadelphia Phillies in the World
Series in 1916 he was even better with
23 wins in another world series titled
this time over the Brooklyn Dodgers in
917 they didn't win but that wasn't his
fault he had 24 wins bringing his total
over three full seasons to 65 an average
of over 20 a year by the end of 1917 he
was considered the best left-handed
pitcher in baseball and if he had
continued on his way he would surely
have been remembered as one of the best
pitchers in the history of the game but
Babe Ruth was a curious Oddity in
baseball a picture that could also hit
well as rules pitchers and hitters are
like two different species of baseball
players in the big leagues each
discipline is so specialized that if
you're good at one you're not good at
the other pitchers are generally so bad
at hitting that in recent decades
they've been replaced in the batting
lineup with a designated hitter so that
they can focus on throwing the ball but
those rules didn't apply to Babe Ruth oh
no he seemed to be just as good at
hitting as he was a pitching so good in
fact that his manager decided to try him
in other positions on days when he
wasn't pitching so that he could keep
his Bat in the lineup in 1918 when the
Red Sox won a third championship and in
1919 Ruth split his time between
pitching and playing in the Outfield and
defied all baseball logic by being good
at both what made Ruth so unique as a
hitter was how hard he could hit the
ball in those days baseball was a game
dominated by pitching and defense while
offense oh would be hard to come by the
Home Run hitting the ball out of the
park for an automatic score was a rarity
with most hitters only managing a couple
of them a season but Babe Ruth he had
home runs and he hit them in bunches in
1919 he set a new Major League record
for home runs hit in a season when he
cracked 29 of them and the crowd
absolutely loved him for it at the end
of the season something happened that
changed the course of baseball history
the Boston Red Sox were owned by Harry
Frazier Broadway show runner that had
spent gobs of money on the team since he
bought them in 1916 to make one of the
best in the league but at the end of the
1919 season he was in deep financial
trouble deeply and dirty risked losing
the ball club and financial ruin unless
he could quickly raise cash the only way
to do this was to sell off the best
assets he had the contract of his star
players Frazee was in a very public Feud
with American League President Dan
Johnson at this point so one of the only
other owners willing to make a deal with
him was Jacob Rupert a co-owner of the
New York Yankees Rupert had made his
fortune in the brewery business but with
prohibition bearing down on the country
he began to rely more and more on his
baseball team for Revenue which meant he
needed a star attraction to put his fans
in the stands the biggest box office
drawing baseball at this point was Babe
Ruth so if Frazee was selling Rupert was
buying Ruth was sold to the Yankees for
a hundred thousand dollars in Cash Plus
a 250 000 loan the news shocked the
baseball world Yankee fans were
delighted while Boston fans were
devastated the sale of Babe Ruth marked
a dramatic reversal of Fortune for both
clubs the Red Sox which had won the
World Series four times between 1912 and
1918 wouldn't win another until 2004 86
years later in that time the Yankees
which that point had yet to appear in
the series would win 26 championships
and become one of the richest and most
storied franchises in all of sports
history as the Decades of futility piled
up Red Sox fans began to believe their
team had been cursed that they were all
being punished for the mortal sin of
sending Babe Ruth to the hated Yankees
foreign
there is a legitimate argument to be
made that Babe Ruth Saved Baseball in
the early 1920s in 1920 during Ruth's
first season with the Yankees eight
members of the Chicago White Sox were
banned from baseball for life after they
were accused of taking money from
gamblers to lose the 1919 World Series
on purpose the black sock Scandal as it
became known threatened the future of
baseball as nobody would pay to watch
games if they believed the results were
fixed Babe Ruth and his prodigious
hitting brought people back to the
stadiums and kept interest in the game
going as baseball weathered the storm
something else happened in 1920 that
Babe Ruth would indirectly benefit from
an on-field tragedy that would change
the way the game was played on August 16
1920 Ruth watched from the field as his
teammate Carl Mays pitched to Cleveland
Indians hit her Ray Chapman the ball got
away from Maze and struck Chapman in the
head fracturing his skull and driving
chips of bone into his brain he took a
few steps toward first base and then
collapsed early the next morning he died
the first and only onville death of a
player in major league history Witnesses
said Chapman never even attempted to
move out of the way of the Fatal pitch
probably because he couldn't see the
ball in those days players typically use
the same baseball for the entire game so
in the later Innings it was dirty and
hard for the batter to see pictures also
routinely applied foreign substances to
the ball like spit or tobacco juice or
Scuff the ball with their fingernails or
an emery board so it moved erratically
making it harder for the battle to
follow after Chapman was killed baseball
Executives decided something had to be
done and changed the rules which persist
to this day baseballs are removed at the
first sign of wear and players are
forbidden from altering the ball or
putting anything on it the rule change
had an immediate effect on the game
offensive production exploded batting
averages went up more runs were being
scored and more home runs were being hit
no one epitomized this change more than
Babe Ruth when he came to the Yankees he
transitioned full time into an
outfielder he would only pitch in five
more games the remainder of his career
1920 marked the start of the Babe Ruth
era as he began to dominate baseball in
a way few other athletes ever have he
absolutely destroyed his own record
hitting 54 home runs next closest player
at only 19. in 1921 he was even better
he set a new record 59 and after only
three full offensive Seasons he already
had the most career home runs in major
league history that year he led the
Yankees their first Penance losing to
the New York Giants in the World Series
[Music]
people packed the stands to watch Ruth
hit wherever he went smashing attendance
records over and over again after the
1921 season Ruth signed a new contract
that paid him 52 000 a year an unheard
of some for a baseball player it was
more than some teams paid their entire
roster despite this he made even more
money from endorsement deals and
exhibition and Vaudeville appearances
than he did from his player contracts
the first athlete in history known to
have done so crowds followed him
wherever he went clamoring for an
autograph or to shake his hand Ruth
reveled in the attention whether it be
from a Schoolboy or a newspaper reporter
Ruth was great copy for the papers
answering every question even silly ones
and always willing to have his picture
taken they competed with each other to
bestow the most outlandish nicknames on
him he was the Bambino the Sultan of
Swat the Colossus clouds the Maharaja of
mash and a dozen others by this point
Ruth was becoming as well known for his
off the field exploits as on-field
production his appetite for food was
legendary he loved to eat and in massive
portions his weight would seize or up
and down a lot over the years Alco was
banned in the United States by this
point but those with money had no
problem getting it if they wanted it and
Ruth put the good stuff away by the
barrel well let's just say that his
stamina in that department as well as
the sheer number of women he disappeared
into hotel rooms with over the years was
legendary among his teammates even if it
tended to be overlooked by the
newspapers in 1922 Ruth was suspended
five times throughout the season for
various offenses after drawing the eye
of everyone from his manager Miller
Huggins to the newly anointed
commissioner of baseball judge Kennesaw
Mountain Landis he had thrown dirt in
the face of an Umpire leapt into the
stairs try beat up a Heckler almost
gotten himself killed in a car accident
and threatened to beat up another umpire
losing for the second year in a row to
the Giants in the World Series was just
the icing on the cake of a disappointing
season Ruth was lambasted by everyone
accused of setting a bad example to the
children that looked up to him and he
promised reform 1923 was the start of a
new era in New York the Yankees have
been playing their home games in the
Giant home park the Polo Grounds once
the Babe arrived Yankee started drawing
more fans to the park than the Giants
did which was embarrassing to the Giants
management they told the Yankees that
police wouldn't be renewed and they were
to play elsewhere Rupert brought lands
in the Bronx and started construction on
a new ballpark Yankee Stadium that
opened during the 1923 season the
dimensions of the new ballpark were
specially designed with Babe Ruth's
swing in mind and it was only fitting
that he christened it with a home run
during the first game played there
Yankee Stadium would become known as the
house that Ruth built then zero would
serve as the Yankees home stadium up
till the end of the 2008 season when it
was demolished to make way for its
replacement the Yankees stormed to the
pennant in 1923 again Facing the Giants
and the third time proved to be the
charm as they finally defeated their
Crosstown Rivals to win the first
championship it was Ruth's fourth as a
player his popularity was as strong as
ever but his poor impulse control would
rear its head again soon enough foreign
1925 was the low point for the Babe both
personally and professionally during
spring training he became dangerously
sick and had to have surgery to repair
what his doctors called an intestinal
abscess the exact nature of his illness
remains a mystery but it seems likely it
had something to do with his hard
partying lifestyle Sports writers
jokingly claimed that Ruth had
overindulged on hot dogs and soda pop
and nicknamed the illness the bellyache
heard around the world around this time
Roots marriage to his first wife Helen
effectively came to an end the two had
buried in 1914 during Babe's first
season with the Red Sox and like many
Teenage romances it was destined for
heartbreak Helen grew increasingly
distressed at her husband's inability to
be faithful to her it is believed that
Dorothy their daughter was adopted the
child of one of Ruth's many Mistresses
finally Helen had a nervous breakdown
and spent much of the next few years in
and out of the hospital the two never
lived together as husband or wife again
though because they were both Catholic
divorce was never considered Ruth's
erratic Behavior finally wore out the
patience of Miller Huggins who suspended
him for over a week and fight him five
thousand dollars initially defied Ruth
eventually apologized and practically
begged to be allowed to play again it
was all part of a disastrous season for
the Yankees who finish next to last in
the league standings people began to say
that the glory years were over that the
Yankees and Ruth were done both would
set out to prove the critics wrong
[Music]
the 1927 Yankees are considered to be
one of the best teams in the history of
baseball their lineup was known as
murderous row with Babe Ruth the
centerpiece of a truly fearsome offense
the Yankees won 110 games winning the
pennant by 19 games of a second place
and barreled through the Pittsburgh
Pirates in four straight to win the
World Series Ruth was in vintage form
breaking the single season home run
record for the fourth and final time
with an even 60 home runs and he was
complimented by first baseman Lou Gehrig
one of the new generation of power
hitters that had come to the big leagues
inspired by The Babe 1927 would prove to
be the Apex of Babe Ruth's legendary
career the summit of the mountain from
then on it would be a slow descent back
to sea level Murderers Row won again in
1928 getting revenge on the St Louis
Cardinals who had beaten them in the
World Series in 1926 but then things
started to go wrong the Philadelphia
Athletics rattled off three pennants in
a row resigning the Yankees to Second
Place the 1929 Miller Huggins Babe
Ruth's only manager while he was with
the Yankees died suddenly leaving the
Yankees leaders Ruth would spend the
rest of his career campaigning to be
named manager himself to the growing
frustration of Yankee Executives the
Great Depression set in hitting ticket
sales and player salaries both meanwhile
Ruth was pulling down 80 grand a year
more than the president of the United
States when asked if he thought it was
right to make more money than the
president Ruth joked that I had a better
year than he did this meant that every
time he got involved in controversy he
started drawing the r of the fans ah he
was unable to dispel with good play
anymore Ruth had fallen victim to the
universal enemy of the athlete father
time as he got older he physically
declined his offensive production nose
diving Ruth had one more moment in the
sun in 1932 the Yankees won the pennant
again facing off against the Chicago
Cubs in the World Series in the third
game in front of a hostile Chicago crowd
Ruth is said to have pointed to a spot
in the center field and then hit a
towering home run there helping the
Yankees to win the game and the series
his seventh championship between the Red
Sox and the Yankees whether or not Ruth
actually called his shot as a matter of
debate among Baseball fans and
historians but like many baseball
stories it almost doesn't matter if it's
true or not what matters is that sounds
good
after two more disappointing Seasons it
became obvious to everyone that Babe
Ruth was done as a player he probably
should have retired at the end of 1934
but he still wanted to manage he
accepted an offer from the owner of the
Boston Braves judge Emma Fuchs agreeing
to an assistant manager player position
with a verbal agreement that he would be
considered for a managerial job in the
future it didn't take long into the 1935
season for babe to realize that had been
tricked the only reason Fuchs had signed
him was as a publicity stunt to draw
fans to his ailing ball Club he had no
intention of ever making Babe Ruth a
manager what was worse is performance in
the field was embarrassing he was a
complete liability as a player now up 28
games Babe Ruth called it quits he
retired with 714 home runs so many that
he had twice as many as the next man on
the career list his former teammate
Garrick Ruth went into retirement still
hoping to become a manager but except
for a half season as a coach with
Brooklyn nobody was interested he ended
up doing what a lot of guys end up doing
when they retire he played a lot of golf
he had toned down his freewheeling ways
in recent years due in large part to his
second wife Claire Phelan died in 1929.
Claire kept a tight Reign on his
finances traveled with him during the
season to help keep him in line Ruth's
retirement was described as being like
an ex-president he was famous but
useless one of the most significant
things he did was appear as himself in
the 1942 movie The Pride of the Yankees
starring Gary Cooper as Lou Gehrig who
had been forced to retire in 1939 after
being diagnosed with ALS which claimed
his life in 1941. Ruth made a number of
public appearances designed to fundraise
for the War epic or entertain the troops
he was so associated with America that
Japanese soldiers were shouting what
they perceived to be the ultimate insult
to their enemies to hell with Babe Ruth
in 1947 Ruth began to feel sick it was a
terrific pain in his head and neck
doctors found cancer growing in his
nasal cavity and his larynx probably
caused by his near-constant cigar
smoking throughout most of his adult
life surgery couldn't get all of the
tumor out and it damaged his voice box
to boot then experimental treatments of
radiation therapy and chemotherapy were
tried but with only limited success and
it soon became clear that he was dying
in June 1948 he appeared at Yankee
Stadium for the last time to celebrate
the 25th anniversary of the 1923 season
he looked noticeably frail using a
baseball bat as a cane as he came out
onto the field two months later he died
age 53.
[Music]
the entire country mourned when Babe
Ruth died for two days Ruth's body Laden
stayed in the Rotunda of Yankee Stadium
while a line of mourners far past the
casket his funeral at Saint Patrick's
Cathedral was attended by 75 000 people
and another 100 000 lined the procession
route to his final resting place at Gate
of Heaven Cemetery most of Babe Ruth's
records have been broken as the decades
have passed most notably his single
season home run record in 1961 and his
career home on record in 1974. today he
ranks third on the all-time list the
fact that he still ranks so highly on
most of these lists a century after he
played is a testament to how good he was
as a player the impact that Babe Ruth
had on baseball could be seen in the way
the game is still being played everson's
owners discovered that fans love to
watch home runs they went out of their
way to give the people what they wanted
more and more players came in that had
home run swings new ballparks were built
to encourage more home runs and in most
modern stadiums hitting a home run is
cause for celebration with fireworks and
sirens and exciting Graphics popping up
on the scoreboard Babe Ruth changed the
way that we think about things too
someone who is a dominant chess player
might be referred to as the Babe Ruth of
Chess and most people will understand
what you're talking about Ruth appears
almost cartoonish today with his goofy
smile and grainy footage often sped up
of him batting it's hard to overstate
how big he was in his day though he
became the most famous man in America in
an age when if you wanted to see a
baseball game you had to go there in
person unless you wanted to read about
it the next day in the newspaper there
was no television radio and movies were
in their infancy and more messages were
being passed by Telegram and telephone
and yet still everyone knew who he was
and they loved him for who it was in
spite of his faults that kind of
adulation seems silly in their cynical
Society we live in today but that's just
how it was back then perhaps the reason
they loved him was because it was
uncomplicated with no ulterior motives
or secret agenda he was just a man who
loved playing baseball sure he loved
other things too but at his core that's
who he was just another baseball fan the
only difference was Babe Ruth was one of
the few people all the baseball loved
back just as fiercely
and probably always will
[Music]